May of 2019 Sam launches a brand new
cryptocurrency exchange FTX he would be
the majority owner whilst Gary Wang who
helped build the infrastructure for it
would own 10% Sam now owned both a
cryptocurrency exchange and a
cryptocurrency trading firm see there's
something already bizarre about this all
and not just the fact that these
companies are being run by Young and
arguably inexperienced people but also
the conflict of interest Sam owning an
exchange is fine whatever but owning his
own trading firm Alam research which
uses FTX as a platform you see that
opens up a gaping hole for example how
exactly does FTX ensure that no special
privileges are given to Alam